bonjour je souhaiterais bien j'assume
tout ego n'a jamais eu de problème de
santé majeur jusqu'à son accident
cardiaque en avril dernier qui a failli
lui être fatal roman de seth rien depuis
longtemps mais on à offrir ça vraiment
été l'homme à malte et à déclencher j'ai
une pneumonie
les antibiotiques ça marchait pas le 21
avril au matin le maire à la peine en
blanc s'est dit capable de me déplacer
jasmin est essoufflé avait de la
difficulté à face aux activités
coutumières ses médecins découvrent une
insuffisance cardiaque terminale
on voit ici le coeur de jasmin
lorsqu'elle s'est présentée juste la
base qui compterait qu'il contracte très
faiblement sa vie est en danger
son état était si inquiétant que
l'équipe a même envisagé une
transplantation cardiaque
on ne pensait que la mise en place d'un
coeur mécanique était peut-être la
meilleure option et qui ont été
optimistes dès le départ qu'il y aurait
peut-être une récupération mais c'est
quand même gros transit par un coeur
mécanique pour retrouver la santé qui
est paul canaud canet se serait décidée
dès son hospitalisation l'équipe
médicale à chercher la cause
cependant certains de faire les amis ce
ticket en la questionnant l'idée est
même venu peut-être de jasmin en disant
qu'elle avait une consommation abusive
de boissons énergisantes ont éliminé les
autres causes fréquentes et le seul
facteur causal qui était mis en évidence
c'est la consommation excessive de
boissons énergisantes qui emmenait son
instance cardiaque terminale j'ai
culpabilisé beaucoup beaucoup coup je me
suis dit plein de gens vont souffrir
plein de gens vont devoir maintenant
consacrer du temps à ma personne parce
que j'ai fait des mauvais choix
la jeune femme dit avoir commencé à
boire des boissons énergisantes vers
l'âge de 16 ans sa consommation est
passée de quelques millilitres à 1 litre
par jour vers l'âge de 21 ans je
travaillais beaucoup à ce moment là
aussi j'ai pas le temps de m'arrêter
pour manger avec à la place
melbourne où deux bourses en argent
jasmine connaissez la mise en garde soin
de ne pas consommer plus de deux
canettes de 250 millilitres par jour
tout comme jasmine le cardiologue mario
sénéchal souhaite sensibiliser
particulièrement les jeunes
quand même épreuve unique mr cofor qui
nous a aidé à prendre conscience de
toxicité des boissons 9
on le sait déjà que les boissons
énergisantes peuvent être
donnez des problèmes de santé chez les
jeunes chez les jeunes adolescents et
she really les gens les jeunes adultes
depuis 2008 également aux états unis au
moins 20 décès on sait que ce sera
portée en relation des boissons
énergisantes
le cardiologue crois même que cela
devrait être interdit pour les moins de
18 ans ce qui est clair pour moi c'est
que les jeunes les adolescents ne
devraient pas consommer de boissons
énergisantes une contre accepter tout à
fait normal l'état de santé de jasmin
s'est beaucoup améliorée grâce au
travail du cac mécanique qui permet de
donner du repos à son coeur ainsi qu'à
son nouveau mode de vie sans boisson
énergisante dont les très optimiste sur
la possibilité d'enlever son coeur
mécanique
nous croyons que lui n'y aura pas de
séquelles que vous récupérer
complètement
je sais que plusieurs personnes vendre
et or mais il ya des restrictions des
avertissements sur les boissons
énergisantes
je suis j'ai mis ma vie en danger en ya
quand même eu conscience que je savais
que c'était pas bon dans mon cas
personnel mans c'est vraiment terminé
ici nicole germain radio canada québec